we're on problem nine use the problem
below to answer the question that
follows
given that a hundred milliliters is
equal to approximately 0.4 cups
205 milliliters is equal to
approximately how many cups so we could
set up a little ratio here we could say
milliliters
is
2.4 cups
as
200 milliliters i'll write the cups here
is e is to how many cups just like that
and so we just have to solve for x to
solve for x we can essentially cross
multiply which essentially just
multiplying both sides of the equation
by both denominators so we get a hundred
x
100 x 100 times x is equal to 200 times
0.4
is equal to well it's not 200 is 205
would be exact 205 times 0.4
is equal to 205
times 0.4 and then we want to divide
both sides by 100 so x is equal to 205
over 100
times
point four
let me write a little bit different
point four just like that we could
divide either by a hundred but let's see
if any of the choices look like what we
have there something times point four
well this one has subtraction and so
that's not our answer this one also has
subtraction not our answer
105 of 0.4 that's the same thing as 1.05
times 0.4
times 0.4 that's the same thing as 2.05
which is exactly what we have here and
just to verify 205 divided by 100 i'll
do it right here
goes into 205 100 goes into 200 2 times
2 times 100 is
200 let me put a little decimal right
there
you do the subtraction you get
bring down a 0 100 goes into 50 0 times
0 times 100 is 0. do a subtraction bring
down another zero 100 goes into 500 5
times 5 times 100 is 500 it all evens
out to 0 so you get 2.05 so this thing
is the same thing as 2.05
times 0.4 which is the same thing as 205
of 0.4
choice d
next problem
all right
we are on problem 10
i'll switch colors
use the number line below to answer the
question that follows okay we have a
number line what number is represented
by point p on the number line above
okay so they give us two endpoints point
zero zero three and point zero zero four
and how many how many buckets do we have
between them we're going one increment
oh sorry i'm on the wrong layer
we go
one increment two increments three
increments four increments five
increments six increments
seven increments
eight
increments so over eight increments
over eight increments we go a distance
of how far
well the distance we go is point zero
zero four
minus point zero zero three which is
just point zero zero one so this whole
distance
this whole distance right there is point
zero
one
point zero zero one and so each of these
are an eighth of point zero zero one
right let me do that in another color
right we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 don't make
it any dirtier so what is what it each
of those are 1 8 of .001 or you could
say it's 8
divided by point zero zero or point zero
zero one divided by eight is how much
each of these increments are and what
we're the point in question is exactly
two increments
past point zero zero three so let's
figure out how far each increment is
it's .001 which is this entire distance
divided by 8. and the best way we can do
this well let's just put a decimal right
there 8 goes into 0 0 times it goes into
zero times eight is zero bring down a
zero
eight times eight goes into zero zero
times bring down a zero
zero there
bring down a one
eight goes into one
zero times 0 times 8 is 0
bring down the 1 you could bring down
another 0 and now it gets interesting 8
goes into 10
one time 1 times 8 is 8
10 minus 8 is 2 bring down a 0 8 goes
into 20 2 times 2 times 8 is 16
20 minus 16 is 4 bring down another zero
eight goes into 40
five
times so it's point zero zero zero one
two five and you might already know that
1 8
1 8 is equal to 0.125 that's something
you might just know from heart and so if
you have this divided by
this isn't we're not dealing with one
we're dealing with
0.0018 so with this divided by a
thousand you're gonna have three zeros
and then
so that and then your one two five so
that's how much each increment is and
we're going two of these increments just
like that so if you multiply this times
what do you get you say 2 times 125 is
250 but we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 numbers
behind the decimal point so 1 2 three
four five six we have just six numbers
behind the decimal point our answer so
that's how much we move
for above
0.003
so essentially so this is going to be
point zero zero zero one two five
another zero zero one two five and it's
all about point zero zero three so our
answer is going to be point zero zero
three plus this
plus point zero zero three
which gets us to point zero
three
and so that is .00325
and i just realized there was an actual
much much easier way to think about
instead of dividing by 8 and all of that
i could have just said you know what
there are eight increments here i've
made this problem messy but there are
eight there are eight increments here
one
two three four five six seven eight
we've gone two of them so we've gone one
fourth of the distance between .003 and
.004
and that would have been the easiest way
to do the problem one-fourth of the
distance is just another 0.25 and that
would have been way easier to do the
problem especially if you didn't want to
waste a lot of time
problem 11
a book distributor is trying to divide
an order of textbooks into equally sized
groups for shipping and cartons the
textbooks can be divided into groups of
12 groups of 15 or groups of 18 with no
books left over so that means that the
number of books we have is divisible by
these three numbers
which of the following inequalities is
satisfied if n is the smallest possible
total number of textbooks so essentially
we know that n is divisible by these
three numbers and we want to find the
least possible end that's divisible by
these three numbers or essentially the
least common multiple of so we want to
let me write this down n is equal to the
least common multiple of 12
and 18. and the easiest way for at least
for me to think about this type of a
least common multiple problem is to just
take the factors of each of these
numbers
let's take the prime factorization of
these guys right here so 12
if we want to take the prime
factorization of 12 it's let's see we
could do a little tree here but it's
pretty easy it's 4 times 3 4 is the same
thing as 2
times 2
times 3. that's 12. so if we just had
the least common multiple of just 12 we
would say well i have to have a 2 in it
times a 2 times a 3. so we have other
numbers here we have a 15. do another
color
15.
15 is equal to what its prime
factorization is 3
times 5.
so our answer right now we already have
a 3 is a prime so to make this divisible
by 15 we just have to include the 5 only
so 3 times 5. so this number right now
is now divisible by both 12 and 15. how
do i know because all of 12 constituent
factors or its prime factors are in this
number and all of 15 constituent numbers
are in this number so this right now is
the least common multiple of 12 and 15
and then we can throw 18 into the mix
so 18
that's the same thing as 2 times 9 or 2
times 3 times 3. and our answer here we
already have a 2 times 3 so already have
these two constituents but we need
another three so let's multiply by
another three now this is going to be
the least common multiple of 12 15 and
18 because it has all of the
constituents of all of these guys you
have one two and two threes one two and
two threes a three and a five you got a
three and a five two twos and a three
two twos and a three you have all the
prime factors of all of these guys and
now you can just multiply see four times
four
sorry two times 2 is 4
times
let me do it times 3 times 5 times 3 4
times 3 is 12 times 5 times 3 12 times 5
is 60
times 3 which is equal to 180 so that is
the least the smallest total number of
books the least common multiple of these
and that means that's choice b 180 is
between 150
and two hundred